it's very exciting to be able to reveal
the plan that we've been working on for
many years finally now it's underway
Miss Marvel is packed
packed from little things like creating
realistic buildings to massive things
like causing major explosions the visual
effects team had their hands full on
this MCU miniseries number one a brand
new character while still honoring the
original one thing that was really
exciting for the VFX team was getting to
create Miss Marvel's powers from scratch
the award-winning team at digital domain
went through multiple iterations of
molicon's powers they wanted it to be an
obvious otherworldly Source while still
honoring the comics origin the team
experimented with color schemes
eventually landing on blue as an Ode to
her hero Captain Marvel to depict the
massive version of Kamala they created a
giant version of the character in Maya
then finished it up by encasing her in
the glow of hard light using Houdini
number two this took a lot more digital
coordination than you think digital
domain VFX supervisor Aladino DeBerry
and his incredible team of artists had a
full workload when it came to creating
settings like a crowded train station
for the scene where Kamala gets
transported into the past they began
with actual footage of a modern day
train station with only a small group of
extras in time appropriate clothing they
added steam to the locomotives in post
and then ran the actors through
Houdini's crowd tool to add extra bodies
to every unnecessarily open space number
three and obeying traffic laws no less
the final scene of Kamala running
through the city was actually inspired
by Spider-Man swinging through his City
they ended up doing all of that
animation by hand because kamala's
platforms aren't totally immovable the
animation team had to play with weight
transfer to get everything to look just
right Aladino talks with Digital Trends
about this complicated sequence you
don't really think about it because it
looks natural but if you go frame by
frame you can see her feet bounce in a
particular way and her body position
changed depending on what kind of
platform she's running on number four
not the class science project you're
used to in this high-powered finale
there are major moments that rely
heavily on the VFX team when our heroes
head back to high school to set some
major Home Alone style traps they fill
the school with what's known as elephant
toothpaste this gray CG foam-like
substance was created by the VFX team
and it's only animated as it expands
throughout the building they actually
spent more time on this 12 second shot
than anything else in the whole show
number five also known as the most
efficient form of transportation
creating kamala's hard light platforms
were pertinent to the VFX team there's
an important scene where she is training
on a rooftop jumping from platform to
platform the sequence utilizes clean
almost virtually clear plates and
digitally generated backgrounds to give
the impression that she is in fact
running through the city rise VFX
supervisor Stuart Bowlen shares one of
the major challenges of perfecting these
platforms there's a narrow window where
the hard light needed to look solid with
a fine balance of opacity versus
opaqueness while avoiding looking like
Crystal so the development of the powers
went through many subtle adjustments
until we settled on the right balance
number six there were at least three
Digi doubles for Kamala the artistic use
of Digi doubles was an important factor
in making sure they could showcase
kamala's powers and the Damage Done to
the city in a realistic Way by working
with full body scans of Iman villani
they were able to create a full body
duplicate of her and several other
characters and place them in dangerous
situations without worry they were also
able to edit the live-action footage and
remove any imperfections that would take
away from the scene Stuart Bowlen shares
with awn what it was like to choreograph
these scenes at times we needed Kamala
to land on the hard light platforms
where they absorbed her kinetic energy
so we relied upon swapping out Iman
villani for our Digi double to allow for
a more natural reaction between the two
number seven some sick visuals here an
important task for the rise VFX team was
being able to show a smooth transition
between the nor Dimension Karachi and
then Earth we settled on glass panes
that rise out of the floor and in
between these panes sand Rises up to
form those worlds this was the first
time that the nor Dimension has been
visually represented in any way in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and so it was
our task to imagine how that should look
Stuart Bowlen describes it as an fx
supervisor's dream number eight more
like the breakable CGI panel most shows
would typically use breakable glass when
it came to bursting through a door but
as you can see the visual effects were
so smoothly done you wouldn't even know
it was CGI unless disclosed Farhan
akhtar's character Walid is shown
bursting through a door at Red dagger's
headquarters and as shown by Rise that
glass panel was completely generated by
the VFX team to ensure a smooth take
number nine a must have for any MCU
battle a major part of depicting the
fight scenes in Miss Marvel were the
utilization of CG weapons Iman villani
and her co-stars would depict the
movements separately and then get
rendered into a digidouble so they could
then place them into a realistically
dangerous fight sequence without needing
an actual prop in place Dort Bullen
explains the fight scenes on set were
carefully choreographed and so how the
hard light platforms move around to the
scenes and are also used as Weapons was
choreographed at rise number 10 let's
get into kamala's iconic MCU Powers we
talked a little bit about how they were
able to depict the Larger than Life
versions of Kamala by using Maya and
Houdini but did you know that her actual
Powers weren't even in the script there
was no actual description of what she
was able to do so they just kind of
figured it out as they went co-director
Bilal fala talks with Slash film about
how nurdin rahali one of the effect
supervisors came up with her Powers he
came up with that design of having this
crystally hard light thing around her
and when he presented it to us we said
that's too cool we're going to keep that
for the finale so that at least we have
our ambiggin moment and that's how
finally it was a good blend between what
was originally in the script and
eventually that homage of the comic
number 11 one of our favorite moments in
the series the iconic lamp post shot
that was taken directly from the comic
book series was beautifully rendered by
the VFX team by utilizing the New York
and New Jersey set extensions green
screen and some impressive CGI animation
they were able to give us This brilliant
final moment we were all waiting for
number 12. New Jersey is a character
within itself to get the vibrant shots
of Jersey City the VFX team created
digital set extensions they wanted to be
able to show every aspect of the City
without having to actually place a
camera over every corner the Bilal fala
explains the artistic decision behind
making New Jersey a character within
itself that's what we wanted to do with
New Jersey and really show all of those
worlds and see the Desi Street and all
this vibrancy that's in a city that we
love and that's part of the world of
Kamala so having that colorful and
dynamic and authentic Street slash Urban
feeling was really important for us to
translate number 13. another great
moment for the VFX team this might come
as a surprise but the iconic mosque
that's used in the show was actually
created with CGI though they did get
real shots from the Fox Theater Krishna
life Temple and Monastery and in the
Islamic Institute of Atlanta for all of
their digital references number 14
working with light bulbs on camera is an
art form when creating kamala's powers
on screen one of the biggest challenges
was getting the lighting just right the
cinematographer Jules O'Loughlin wanted
to do as much as possible on camera so
they didn't have to leave everything to
the VFX team it's a real dance between
getting lighting fixtures on the set but
hiding them from the camera I used
larger than lighting fixtures off camera
for energy walls and the light and then
smaller LEDs behind her arms or in her
clothes hiding smaller units around the
set number 15 we're here for every panel
one thing the LOL follow really wanted
to do when it came to Bringing Miss
Marvel to life was utilize a comic book
style animation when showing what it was
like to be inside kamala's head he talks
to slash film about the inspiration
behind that we were a bit afraid that
Marvel wouldn't do that because it's
totally different than all of the other
shows so we really tried to present this
presentation to Kevin feige to show that
with animation we can go inside her head
her Fantasyland and Her Imagination
without this aesthetic they would have
been Limited in kamala's
characterization after learning all the
visual effects secrets from digital
domain and Rise we're even more
impressed with Miss Marvel's hard light
Powers the beautiful set of New Jersey
and the seamless incorporation of
Animation to create this modern MCU
Universe what was your favorite moment
in the series